this strategy is so secret honey once
you tell your parents about me can you
be trusted as you were this is our new
signal as soon as you get on base you
look at me if you see that my hat is
turned around like this when you get to
the next face you slide and pretend that
you injured your leg hold on to it yell
squirt a few tears that shouldn't be a
stretch for most of you and why do I
want you to do this so that I can take
you out and put a faster runner in and
maybe score a run that we wouldn't have
gotten otherwise this is a very special
strategy for our slower runners rusty
you would be a top candidate and if
lightning should strike and Frankie you
happen to find yourself one base I want
you go ahead and clean your glasses off
and take a look at my hat this isn't a
strategy this is cheating I have no
problem with you stop talking right now
Michael if we can't find a way to win
fair and square I for one would rather
lose you cannot stand in front of people
in their formative years and say that
you would rather lose I would rather
lose than please don't waste our time
quoting from the handbook of curling
this is baseball this is wrong
[Music]
welcome you are the luckiest kids you're
on my team and I have just one rule I'm
[Music]
sorry traffic for something believe this
is very important this is about the play
not about the winning of the losing see
Mike winning is fun let up when we draft
new kids on the team let me do the
talking we wrap just dad you're coaching
the pirate with me so we already have
Ralph Johnson's not my son who is your
son I smell a hit Frankie planet and
turn let's get this season's to a great
start
kind of a noisy loser doesn't bother you
really remember every game you won in
lost as a kid when I was 12 when 11 and
4 and lost the championship game when
Billy Nathan got picked off third with
two outs in the last inning
well you have a very good memory
[Music]
whatever that was it what in baseball I
thought we said we're gonna get on the
kids about physical error tell me
something why are you here
I'm tired dawn I need a break
like I'm asking you to be honest and
that's a hard thing I was a kid who
never got picked
I don't want Frankie to be the kid in
every good spec that's why I'm here
I see our job creating a safe nurturing
atmosphere where the kids aren't afraid
failure
I need to feel hope I wanna know there's
purpose for all this
see I'm he's a pretty big thing you
haven't change your socks help look Mike
I'm your doing I think the team I got a
confession McDon I really want to win we
were turning into a real baseball man
badly
one more curveball and you will find
yourself on this spring musical and
nobody wants to be that guy Jimmy
you
you